We're not just building condos offices.
We're building beauty and culture.
We're building community.
But between you and me, we just made over
$20 million on our last project.
How's that for beauty?
As I walk past Homer and Richards
screen, pass
another new construction
within three blocks.
I couldn't help but wonder why do this?
Keep building new buildings
when we have so many old buildings
that are falling apart?
You know, the building
industry accounts for
40% of the entire world's
carbon footprint.
So if we really wanted to slow down
global warming,
we should be focusing
on renovating our existing
building stock.
We lost so much money
on our last renovation.
That idiot architect missed
a bunch of stuff
and the existing building,
aren't we charge for every penny, but
not one of those to be a six months job.
Not a whole friggin year.
We just want to get in
and get it for a living.
But a boom with a new building.
At least it's straightforward
and I think
as an architect,
I'm used to hearing this all the time.
But is this really the right way forward?
This building came very close
to being demolished
and replaced by a brand new building.
But instead, it received a $200 million
renovation against all the odds.
In case you haven't heard of this
building, this is the infamous Portland
building.
A 15 story municipal office building
that people hated
pretty much from its inception.
Not only did it look well, kind of weird,
but there were structural problems.
It was built with cheap materials,
and these
tiny windows
made the spaces very dark from the inside.
This building actually became almost a
joke to the civil servants who work there.
Despite its shortcomings,
when it actually came down
to deciding whether they should
demolish it or save it.
Certain things came to fruition
that changed the fate of this building.
The building was built in 1982
by the American architect Michael Graves,
and it's considered one of the earliest
examples of postmodern architecture.
Postmodernism began
in the mid-20th century as a reaction
to modernism,
which people were really starting
to think was boring, very boring.
So architects like Robert Venturi
and Michael Graves started to play around
with historical references,
bright colors, unconventional forms.
And unlike modernism, it tried to better
connect with its context.
So when they started discussing
the demolition of the Portland building,
an architect nominated
this building to be added
to the National Register
of Historic Places.
So what saved this building in the end
was its consideration
as a historically
significant piece of architecture.
But not every building is so lucky.
These are all architecturally
significant buildings that were torn down.
And that's because what's considered
heritage can be subjective
and it can often come down to my opinion
versus your opinion.
Just look at some of this language.
Historically significant architecture
must embody
the distinctive characteristics of a type
period or method of construction,
or that represents the work of a master
or that possesses
high artistic values,
or that represent a significant
distinguishable entity whose components
may like individual distinction.
Properties must also retain integrity.
And yeah, feeling is one of them.
For older buildings
that don't meet any of this criteria,
as soon as they reach about 50 years old
or even sooner in some buildings,
they are subject to an assessment
where they look at the performance,
the mechanical systems,
the envelope, the structure
and we try to see how much money and time
it would take
to upgrade the building systems
to a building code minimum.
And based on that, we try to assess
the feasibility of the upgrade.
If it's a public building.
We will also try
to get the community's input
and sometimes it can definitely get
a little bit political.
I mean, the community's going to be
the ones paying for the project,
so they need to determine
are they willing to pay extra taxes
for this brand new community center
or are they okay with a piecemeal
renovation of their existing one?
But is this criteria
really enough to determine
whether a building
should be saved or demolished?
Can you show me what would happen
if we were to demolish everything
and replace it with a whole new building?
Let's let's say, of the same size
in concrete?
Absolutely.
So I'm going to go back
to the current page here.
Switch from renovation
to new construction and chain destruction
system from steel to concrete.
And once we make that change,
what the project teams did is
go to renovation.
They were preserving
100% of this substructure.
about 75% of their superstructure.
And they were redoing the enclosure
100% from scratch.
So let's say
we keep the preserve number to zero.
And the same thing.
For two years they were redoing
the interiors from scratch again.
If I click on
Save here, the actual achievable embodied
carbon number for the project came down
from about a million cases
a year to E to about 454,000 CO2.
So they got an almost 50% reduction
in embodied carbon
just by doing a renovation.
Now you guys might be wondering
why the heck is
she talking about embodied carbon?
The building industry accounts
for 40% of the world's CO2 emissions,
and the earth, as you know, is burning
Ambati carbon is the silent killer
in carbon emissions.
It makes up almost half
of the total construction emissions.
If you don't know what it is,
embodied carbon is the carbon
that's created before
and after a building's life cycle.
So that's where your materials
are coming from during the extraction,
the manufacture, the transportation,
construction, all of them of a building.
And once the buildings
reach the end of its life
during the replacement and the demolition
and the deconstruction of a building
and 80% of embodied
carbon can actually be reduced
if it's evaluated early
in the design phase,
because that's when you're determining
some of the most important factors,
like the massing,
the structural framing, the support
structure, the floor
and the foundation and the roof.
But the problem right now is that we
almost never have enough information
when all of the key decisions
are being made,
for instance, whether we should renovate
or demolish a building.
And this is because for us to do
an embodied carbon calculation,
first of all, the architect
needs to work on a massing scheme
and then they need
to send that to the structural engineer
who is going to create their own model,
which we would use to estimate
the structural quantities,
and then we can estimate the carbon
emissions from those massing schemes.
In most projects,
the timelines are so tight
that we don't have the capacity to do this
every time.
In other cases,
we will get an outside consultant
to do a full lifecycle assessment.
But that's really expensive
and it could take months and months
and either way, the calculations typically
happen way too late in the design phase.
Okay, let's
get back to the Portland building.
So did you create this
just based off an architectural
massing model or did you have to put in
any structural information?
What we have done
is basically use the architectural massing
of the actual building geometry
and apply
the principles of structural engineering
in the back in an automated fashion
to estimate the quantities
of different structural elements.
So even if you don't have
the quantity information for how much,
how many columns do you have
in the building or beams or slabs?
We have estimated those quantities to
about an 85 to 95% accuracy automatically.
So you don't need
structural engineers anymore.
I think what we are trying to do is bridge
a big gap that we saw in the industry
is the availability of information
when the decisions are being made.
So at no point do you trying to replace
any expert on the project.
What we are doing is basically providing
designers of the project team
members a starting point,
but then the engineers jump on the project
when they have more accurate information.
They can always just override manually
this information and make better decisions
off that by having access to this
information early in the design process.
We can have a much bigger impact
on the sustainability of a building.
So they just passed
a new international building code
saying that we can build a building
in heavy timber up to 18 storeys
and engineered wood up to 15 storeys,
which is the same size
as the Portland building.
So yeah, can we see the difference
if we were to build this out of timber
from the beginning?
Let's switch it to new construction
and switch the structural system type
from concrete to mass timber.
And once we do that,
you can see how the numbers is updated.
And even if you're going
into a new construction with mass timber,
the total achievable embodied
carbon emissions for your project
would still remain fairly low
as compared to a new construction done in
concrete or maybe in steel.
Yeah,
because what we saw before with concrete,
that was about a million, right?
Yeah, that was pretty high. Yeah.
So if we had this in mind from
the beginning, we could have saved around
700,000 cages. CO2.
Although the decision
for saving the Portland
building was not necessarily due
to its environmental impact.
You can actually see
just how much of a difference
that made to the carbon emissions.
And not just that the renovation
has significantly improved
the building's building performance
and now it's on track to earn LEED Gold.
The ironic part
is that now after the renovation,
the building might actually lose
its status on the National Register
of Historic Places because apparently
it's been changed too much.
I'm sure as we get more
and more aging buildings
and as we get better energy measures
in the construction industry,
we will be asking ourselves
how we can preserve the integrity
of the historic building
while improving its function
and hopefully embody carbon becomes not
a sustainable city target,
but just a part of our everyday practice.
As architects.
We can start by adopting apps
like Cove Tool into our everyday toolbox.
So comparing
embodied carbon is just another
part of the design process,
like doing a Sun study.
And we can also have these conversations
with the stakeholders really early on
in the design process.
But until then, tools like this
can empower us.
We can have conversations
about the practicality
of tearing down a building or
renovating it from an energy standpoint.
And because we can have this data
as early as pre design,
we can actually have a really big impact
on the carbon footprint of a project.
So what do you guys think?
What kind of changes do you think
we need to make in the building industry?
Let me know in the comments.
And with that,
I'll see you guys in the next video.
If you like this video, please
give me a thumbs up
and subscribe to the channel
and I will see you guys in the next video.
This video is sponsored by Cove Tool.
A portion of this video
is sponsored by Cove Tool.